all right Merle
welcome back thank you you I think more
than any person I've ever interviewed
you got more requests for a follow-up
interview than I think it's so great to
be loved
[__] you
your brother your brother kind of
made you notorious you guys were both
yeah very very
well known well loved in uh in the punk
rock Community well loved and well hated
believe me yeah yeah so which is fine
you know what as long as people are
talking that's all that [__] matters
that's what your brother would have
loved right yep tell me a little bit
about your brother so for okay viewers
that don't know my brother was the most
notorious
the most outrageous the most dangerous
rock and roll performer of all time bar
none
his live shows
are legendary
they consisted of nudity
self-mutilation
defecation masturbation
lots of blood lots of blood lots of
violence
confrontations with
audiences yeah lots of fighting
um
oral sex on stage with men and women
people leaving shows with broken bones
or on stretchers I'm not [__] this
all happened this was the 80s right this
was the early 80s 80s and 90s the 90s
because in the 90s was the time period
that the murder Junkies
we're touring with my brother yeah even
though like the sex pistols and some of
the bands that were so notorious early
on in the punk scene
um
you and your brother became
you almost represented that community
that better than anyone
well in terms of that I mean I mean you
know we obviously were influenced by you
know the early Punk stuff The Ramones
The Sex Pistols The Dead Boys all that
stuff and as they kind of folded off or
I think my brother was disillusioned by
all of it by the fact that he felt that
a lot of those bands sold out started to
sell out and he stayed true to his guns
uh throughout his whole career whether
people liked it or not I mean the
critics
hated it I mean there was not ever one
good [__] write-up about anything GG
Allen ever did
you know if if he had been more like
soft and [__] [__] punk and and all
that [__] you know like sugar-coated
[__] punk rock that there is today
people would have loved him but you know
when you write songs about murder and
rape and torture and killing and you
know all that [__] he stuck to his guns
people don't take you serious or they
they just
they don't want to hear that yeah unlike
a lot of the other Punk
you know
before him yeah he didn't he'd never
really mellowed out no not at all I mean
he took it to extreme levels you know I
mean there was nobody doing anything
like he was doing yeah where's that come
from
you know
growing up
we had a really tell me about your
family growing up thank you tell me
about your family growing up okay well
my mom met my dad
1953 54.
uh she was 17 [__] years old my dad
was like 30 Something New Hampshire in
New Hampshire the rural New Hampshire
in a small town of Lancaster New
Hampshire
and she got pregnant right away so they
got married
1955 April 1955 I came along and a year
a little over a year later my brother
came along and uh we were both born and
weeks Memorial Hospital in Lancaster New
Hampshire population
3 000 something like that
we grew up
in a three-room log cabin on an rfd2
Road
between
Lancaster and Groveton in a town called
northumborn
we lived in a
three-room Log Cabin
with no running water
uh you have electricity electricity we
had but we had no running water we had
to go to Wells and bring big jugs of
water to we had no shower no bathtub we
had a small kitchen you walk into the to
the
to the cabin there's a small kitchen
off the kitchen there's a one small room
with a toilet
no
you know bathtub no shower no sink no
nothing a toilet that's it
the next room is the living room which
also
was my mom and dad's bedroom
and the third room
which was so small we had to we had to
sleep literally in bunk beds
so that was the first
10 years of our life we lived with a
domineering father it was very strict
I mean he named
me after him so I'm Merle Jr but he
named my brother Jesus Christ Allen
so Gigi's real name is Jesus Christ his
real name was Jesus Christ Allen up
until
up until he went into the first grade
and my mom
I don't know how she how she ended up
getting him to change it but
she changed it to Kevin Michael Allen
so so that that begs the question what
what was going on with your dad that he
named your brother Jesus Christ well my
dad you know was a [__] nut job I
mean he was like he was a religious
fanatic who did not follow what he
preached he did not practice what he
preached he would send us off to [__]
church every Sunday and he would stay
home just because he wanted to get rid
of us for the day you know so
um yeah
so that was basically we were pretty
isolated as kids we didn't have
neighbors with kids to play with
um so we basically
you know
entertained ourselves by
playing outside and you know we we were
able to
hear music
my dad had
records like Merle Haggard he had some
Johnny Horton
uh some Willie Nelson Hank Williams
stuff like that so that's
that was our first introduction to music
you know you and Gigi were close
oh yeah yeah me and Gigi were very close
yeah I mean we had nobody else you had
no one else you know so and we were
close to our whole life you know uh so
yeah so basically
we really didn't have uh anything we
were a dirt [__] poor you know what
was your dad doing for work my dad
worked in a paper mill in Groveton and
my mom worked like odd jobs as a
waitress you know at little restaurants
and stuff like that you know
uh but we had no we had no [__] money
you know and uh
we had you know we really had to Bear
Necessities you know we a big day for us
would be going into Lancaster which is
the little town and there was a little
store there Sammy evans's and they had a
candy counter right under a big glass
saying this is like you know the 50s
early 60s right and uh they had Penny
Candy and we were like if we had five or
ten cents to buy candy we were like you
know that was a great day for us you
know what were you guys like as like
high schools years teenage years teenage
years
well I'm getting up to that um
you know we my mom left my dad my dad
raped my mom
like we went to school one day
we came home
my mom the next day she took us out of
the house and we left we were gone this
was 1965.
and my apparently my dad had raped my
mom like continuously the whole day
before and that was the last straw she
was like [__] this I'm done were there
drugs involved in your dad Tesla drugs
no no just very my dad was very
anti-social he didn't want people around
so we were sheltered for the first 10
years of Our Lives we
like I said we didn't play with kids we
had hardly ever had company the only
company we ever had was a doctor because
the doctors made house calls back then
so we were sick all the time because
my dad like when it snowed in the winter
he would let the snow accumulate and
cover up the cabin because he didn't
want people like
seeing or coming to our house or
whatever you know and so we were always
sick in the winter my brother had asthma
when he was young
so yeah we uh we had a rough start you
know and then after my mom
finally left my dad
we went to
live with my grandmother
who my grandmother was the main reason
that my mother
married my father to begin with because
she wanted to get away from a
domineering mother
so she marries my father who's almost as
dominating as her mother was but so we
ended up living with my grandmother for
a few years
in her house and then she had a house
that was next to her house and we went
we had one of the units in her other
house so we were living right next to my
grandmother where was this this was in
Lancaster yep and uh
at that time I mean uh as I said in the
last
interview we had seen the Beatles on The
Ed Sullivan Show and that kind of uh
cemented what we wanted to do with our
life you know as it did for many people
but you know when you're as isolated as
we were you know it was like wow
what is this that's going on out here
you know and and once my mom left my dad
we were able to have a little bit more
freedom especially with my mom working
and stuff so it gave us more time to you
know raise hell and do [__] and find
experiment and stuff but we had a friend
that uh
my mom had a friend who had a daughter
that was a few years older than us
and she was into all the British
Invasion music like Herman's Hermes I'm
see Dave Clark Five uh
all that stuff so we started listening
to stuff like that and
then eventually we left
New Hampshire and moved to Lunenburg
Vermont we were basically on the border
of Vermont New Hampshire where we lived
so we moved to Lunenburg Vermont and at
this time we're you know starting to be
in our early teens
and uh
it's like you know we heard we were
hearing bands like Led Zeppelin their
first album
early 70s Aerosmith was like
Gods to us you know early Aerosmith I
mean we saw Aerosmith play at Plymouth
State College when dream on was just
breaking you know and uh I mean we saw
we would hitchhike to concerts
all the time we would we saw the
original Alice Cooper Band in 72.
we saw the Ziggy Stardust tour
um Grand Funk Railroad Led Zeppelin kiss
every [__] fan you know any chance we
had to see a band
we would hitchhike like
Maine we hit psyched up to Montreal a
lot to see shows uh you know and we were
just [__] teenagers you know I mean I
wouldn't I don't think I would do that
today but
but back in the 70s it was you know it
was a lot more innocent times and you
could do [__] like that and get away
with it you know but uh
so yeah we were going to a lot of shows
and we were collecting records I mean
music we basically were living music 24
7. everything involved in our life was
about music we would go to department
stores and steal records we would break
into cars we'd break into like summer
houses to
get whatever we could do to sell stuff
to buy music that's what we did all the
time you know
my mom even called the cops on us once
yeah she found a stash of stolen goods
in in the closet
and she called the [__] game warden
up on us and the [__] came down and
confiscated all of our [__] but I mean
it was it was more like a something to
do you know I mean we were bored kids in
a small town with nothing going on and
did your brother always have that
defiant
anti-establishment
well you know it's funny because growing
up we were I mean being we were the kids
in our town
that everybody talked about you know
there's always that there's always one
or two weirdos in your town that like oh
that guy stay away from him you know
um
we were those guys you know I mean my
brother
we got picked on a lot because you know
we grew up with a lot of rednecks and
farmers and [__] ugly [__] fat
chicks and you know so we never got laid
and we didn't really care we were all
just about music you know uh
but yeah so we got picked on a lot
because we were different you know I
mean
my brother would go into like department
stores and buy clothing in the women's
Department you know he had like these
really cool like [__] green pants
with big white [__] dots off
and then he had these like yellow
[__] bright yellows like like jeans
and stuff and you know
nobody was nobody dressed like that
where we were from you know people were
wearing [__] coveralls and [__]
straw hats and and you know flannel
shirts and [__] you know uh and at that
point
you know we were we were into the Glam
you you know we were obviously into
Alice Cooper and and uh you know T-Rex
and and the New York Dolls this was 1973
you know and uh and all that kind of
stuff so we you know playing music back
then we wanted to
dress the part you know and like all the
people that we were influenced and
idolized you know and uh and we went to
concerts all the time so we saw like
just all these great costumes and
outfits and leather and silk pants and
you know uh weird clothes and that's the
kind of [__] we wanted to wear you know
and uh
so this is you know at this point we're
we're starting to play music we it took
us a while to to be able to play music
because we didn't have the funds to go
out and buy equipment you know
um
so around
1975 we formed our first band together
it was a band called little sister's
date
and
we played from like 1975 to
early 1976 I would say we played well we
played to Bicentennial so it would have
been I guess mid 1976.
um
we didn't play a lot of shows we played
some outdoor shows and stuff like that
but we weren't really ready to uh play
clubs and stuff yet you know we were
just we were still learning how to play
we were playing like you know the kind
of songs we were playing where like
anything that was three or four chords
that we could actually play over and
over the same thing you know because we
weren't good enough to play any I mean
my brother was a very good drummer you
know but in 1976 the punk scene was just
beginning yeah yeah so
um so we were playing and and the thing
is you know we were a band from New
Hampshire and all the other bands
from that era that lived in New
Hampshire they were all playing like
your top 40 music
so you you know you you go to a uh you
go to a dance you go to a show and
listen to a band You're Going to Hear
The Doobie Brothers You're Going to Hear
China Grove you're going to hear
everything that's popular at that time
every band was playing
except us
now we were playing like Aerosmith
kiss
some some Iggy Pop uh some MC5 uh
just off the wall [__] Black Sabbath you
know the kind of stuff that nobody was
playing at clubs
at that time for sure you know it was
all about making money and top 40 was
the way to go nobody was playing
anything original
you know
so
um
but that van didn't last very long
and I was actually still playing guitar
at that point and uh
we couldn't keep it going so that van
folded pretty quickly and the next
band that we got together would have
been the same year
was a band called malpractice
now
malpractice formed
me and my brother
and a guitar player from Gorham New
Hampshire
his name was Jeff and he was really a
good guitar player real good guitar
player and at that point we had all
gotten better at our instruments so we
were actually
sounded like a real band you know
and uh
so we started playing shows and we
actually
but but we were playing the same kind of
song Still I mean at that point you know
1976 1977 we were even throwing in
Ramon's songs because the first Ramones
album we'd heard and once we heard the
first Ramones album that was like the
end right there you know no more no more
of this [__] Arena Rock [__] we were
all gung-ho for three chord punk rock
you know simple stripped down
say what you got to say and end this
[__] song You Know
so
we were traveling around we were doing
like Maine New Hampshire Vermont circuit
um
playing a lot of the same songs I mean
we you know we threw in like a you know
Peter Frampton song or Steve Miller song
you know you have to
throw in something here and there that
people are going to want to hear but uh
but back in those days
you know you would go and you were all
by yourself you know it's not like today
there's four or five bands on a bill
right we had to travel with our own
equipment we had to bring a sound system
with us
um
we were traveling in like this big
[__] like Howard Johnson's red truck
right with no [__] heat right so
where and then you know in the winters
and [__] New Hampshire Maine New
Hampshire Vermont are [__] cold you
know so we would travel to shows and
we'd be wearing like ski skidoos
snowmobile outfits
in the in the van in the right truck
because it was so [__] cold you know
and uh you go to a show and you'd like
play three or four sets every night
you'd probably make like a hundred two
hundred dollars
for the whole thing you feel the whole
bed yeah you know but
once again we didn't give a [__] we
didn't care about the money nobody cared
about the money back then
it's all about [__] we're playing
[__] music we're [__] living our
[__] dream here we're in a van we're
traveling to shows we're playing clubs
and people are showing up to see us play
that was like magic for us
I don't give a [__] about the money
we could have lost money and it still
would have been fine you know
and uh
that that went pretty well for a while
like everything else it kind of burned
itself out you know we we recorded a
record we did do it a single it was the
very first record
that me and my brother had ever done
together so you know we thought we were
pretty [__] special man we thought we
were [__] big time
you know we did we did a single called
um
Devil's Triangle and love tunnel
and uh you know we had these we you know
we were young right we had this image of
oh we recorded a record man now what's
next now we gotta get signed to a big
label and and hit the big time right you
know I mean that was that was like our
Dream but
of course that didn't happen we were we
were just another band you know and
and uh at that point
like I said we had already seen the
Ramones and at that point
um
heard the Ramones and at that point the
whole Punk thing started to uh come
along and Gigi basically
was tired of playing drums he wanted to
be the he wanted to be the guy he wanted
to be the guy out front
so
he stopped playing drums
and
reverted back to the name that I gave
him when he was born Jesus Christ Allen
because
when I was just you know this High I
couldn't say Jesus so I would say Gigi
so the nickname for Jesus was Gigi and
so he picked that name back up
after he decided he wanted to be a front
man
and
around 1978
[Music]
malpractice had folded
um
we were looking you know we had
we had played in Boston
with malpractice we'd played in New York
City with malpractice so what happened
the first time you guys went to New York
City
must have opened it was a culture shock
you know
I tell people today I'm like
you know that movie Taxi Driver
that's what New York City was like in
1977. 42nd Street pimps hookers pawn
shops XXX everywhere you know it was
amazing I mean we were bumpkins
from New Hampshire
but we were
we've like fell in love with the filth
and the dirt and the grime and just the
grittiness of like what was going on
there you know
and
I mean that was just a I guess that was
kind of just a part of us because that's
kind of how our music
was was starting to form and everything
so
um
yeah but it was quite a culture shock
for sure you know but but we loved it
you know and uh
so that year
my brother and I had put an ad
in the Boston Phoenix
which is you know the weekly
entertainment paper and there was a
section in the back for uh gigs
people looking for gigs and stuff like
that so we had put an ad
in the Boston Phoenix
and we got a reply
from
um
a guy named Johnny Angel
was in a band called thrills
and they had
been together maybe a year or two
they'd already played with the
stranglers they were already like
established
in the scene in New York in Boston
and Johnny calls up and says hey you
guys want to audition
and we were like [__] yeah so Johnny
Angel drove from Boston up to Vermont
to audition us
well we passed the audition
but
my brother decided
he didn't want to move to Boston
and he didn't want to be
a drummer he wanted to be a front man he
wanted to do his own thing
and I jumped at the opportunity
so
and then in the meantime we were both
working like shitty jobs you know shoe
factory he was working at a shoe factory
I was working uh
bottling Maple Syrup and Honey in
somebody's basement you know
so
basically what and plus Gigi had uh
was waiting for his
high school sweetheart
yeah
I hate to say it but Gigi was [__]
whipped at that time
I know you're not going to believe that
but it's true so Gigi was kind of [__]
whipped and he was waiting for Sandy to
graduate high school
and
he basically just wanted to do his own
thing me I wanted to move I wanted to
get the [__] out I wanted to move to
Boston I wanted to play with this man's
Thrills so
I would work all week
I'd Rent A Car on the weekend I would
drive down to Boston I would rehearse
with the band
I would drive back home go back to work
and I did that for about a month
and then I was ready
I moved to Boston
when I was like 22 years old
and never went back
well I went back to visit but I went
back for my brother's wedding which was
the same year 1978 he got married Sandy
graduated high school and they got
married in October
I went to the wedding actually
malpractice got up and played a couple
of songs
you know so and and also
we had already recorded
me and my brother had already recorded
the first jabber single
which was
Gigi's first real band was with him
fronting was GiGi Allen and the jabbers
but we had already recorded the single
before there was even a band before I
moved this would have been 1977 or so
that we recorded the single and then I
moved to Boston started playing with
Thrills and Gigi got married moved to
Manchester New Hampshire which is about
an hour from Boston
and he formed the jabbers and so I was
playing shows with Thrills he was
playing shows with the jabbers and uh a
couple of times he actually his band
actually opened for tyrells you know we
were we were popular we were like throws
was like one of those
bands that was a weekend headliner
so we also got to open for big bands
that would come to town we opened for
the Ramones we opened for the cars we
opened for you two I mean we opened for
a lot of
big bands you know and
my brother was
doing his thing in Manchester uh and
becoming
notorious he was like they called him
the madman of Manchester New Hampshire
because
um
the the jabbers the poor jabbers they
were so frustrated with my brother
because
they would rehearse for hours and hours
and and they were a really good band
they were [__] tight solid had great
songs my brother was a master songwriter
yeah
they had really great songs but they
would go out to shows
and my brother would
start
doing [__] and get thrown out you know I
mean I mean it was a gradual progression
he wasn't like [__] on stage in 1978
you know uh but you know he would go out
and and flip people's tables or you know
take somebody's drink and pour it on
their head or pour it in their face or
[__] like that or you know hang from
[__] water pipes from the stage and
and just you know doing
little [__] like that but still stuff
like that got you thrown out of Club
what was your brother's personality like
on stage was he a different person than
who he was in real life oh absolutely
absolutely yeah because I mean
and and like I say that gradually
got more and more violent I mean you
know in the early late 70s
early 80s it was more innocent kind of
like
craziness you know
but as
things progressed and I just I feel that
my poor brother got trapped in his own
Insanity maybe or he just he because he
always seemed to have to push the
envelope a little bit more you know
Batman Persona became yeah and once you
you have that kind of persona and and
yeah people expect things of you then
you have to take it to another level and
then you've got to take it to a Next
Level and that's kind of how it worked
out
um of course
as he got a little older and the more
alcohol consumption
that
didn't help matters at all you know and
the drug thing I mean you know my
brother was not a junkie by any means he
really
didn't do heroin hardly at all you know
I mean he'd do whatever you gave him if
you gave him drugs he'd take them he
wouldn't even ask you what they were he
just take them but he wasn't a junkie
and he wasn't you know drugs was not his
problem
alcohol was
yeah so
as he
as he progressed you know I mean
jabra's first album was came out in 1980
great record
he would come down to Boston and play I
would go to his shows
[__] the jabbers were amazing band
they were [__] really great but in
the Boston scene
nobody cared they weren't cool in Boston
at all you know so they were not a
headliner at all they would come down on
a Tuesday or Wednesday night and play
for maybe 30 people or something you
know there was no uh
but I mean like I said none of us cared
at that point even even at that stage
and I just gave a [__] about money
we're just happy to be playing you know
I mean
think of this in 1977
I'm working a shitty job
in New Hampshire I'm going to work every
day with homemade cassette tapes
of the Ramones The Dead Boys The Sex
Pistols all that [__]
a year later I'm living in Boston and my
band is opening for the Ramones and The
Dead Boys and all of these [__] bands
so you don't think I was in my [__]
Heaven I mean
that was that was like
that period of my life
probably one of the best periods of my
whole life
because rock and roll was still new the
punk scene was still new
bands were
experimenting and
man sounded different not every band
sounded the same because everybody was
trying to make their own way you know
and it wasn't like oh this man's really
popular let's let's get on the bandwagon
so we can sound like them so we can you
know be popular it wasn't like that
everybody had a different sound
and it was unique and it was new and
fresh and and a lot of it was really
great I still listened to a lot of
the old bands from the
late 70s early 80s that I used to go see
in Boston all the time I still listen to
that stuff today because
it's held out through the test of time
the 70s I think for music we're both the
best and the worst decade absolutely
well I would say the 80s would be
considered that too because the 70s I
mean yeah there was you're right there's
a lot of great stuff in the 70s a lot of
traffic but but like radio in the 70s
was awful
yeah a lot of things are awful about oh
yeah popular music but we didn't care
about the radio we were we never you
know we never wrote a song or made music
or did anything
to get on the radio
or even to be popular we didn't care we
did what we liked to do
and if people liked it that was great
and if they didn't like it [__] you I
don't give a [__]
you know
so yeah as as Gigi progressed
um
through the 80s
it was he was playing with different
well you know the jabbers
had broken up and then reformed into a
three different you know
uh
deals but uh
they just got frustrated with him
because they would rehearse and rehearse
and and go to a show and the show would
last like 10 minutes and you'd get
thrown out and that'd be the end of that
so
so that's when he started uh
kind of doing different things with
different bands you know
um
did stuff with a band called the scum
Fox
did stuff with
uh this 1985 1985.
that was the beginning right there that
was the first time
that Gigi defecated on stage
in a VFW Club
in Peoria Illinois
a guy named bloody mess
who was a fan and also had his own band
lived in Peoria
invited Gigi out for a show
and that was the first time
that he had defecated on stage
and we were just like my my poor mom and
my stepdad
they just couldn't believe it you know
and and I was even like trying to you
know be like what are you doing man I
mean you're [__] really talented you
know I mean my brother if my brother had
decided
to clean up his act and actually
play the game he could have been some he
could have been someone not I'm not
saying that he isn't someone because he
definitely is he's a [__] Legend but
he could have been commercially
successful because
he really was a master songwriter if he
chose to go more mainstream if he had
chose to go more mainstream he could
have done good things you know I mean
that first jobber's record is
power pop uh rock and roll it's it's
[__] really great record you know and
it's
it's really not that foul I mean there's
a song called ass face and you know [__]
like that but but for the most part it
wasn't that bad but
the progression just got you know
I mean he's writing songs like you know
I want to [__] myself and you know
needle up my [__] and and you know scum
[__] tradition and [__] [__] sucking
Cannibal and was it just for shock value
that he did a lot of that stuff you know
he just he just wrote songs about the
real reality of life you know and
in the rock and roll business they like
love songs and songs that the mainstream
can connect with and you know people
aren't connected with hey girl girl
girls give me give me give me some head
you know I mean
mainstream people don't want to hear you
know you got VD and you had a needle up
your [__] nobody wants to hear that
you know I mean not everybody wants to
hear that anyway I mean so Gigi became
more of like a cult thing you know and
uh
boy who's hated though he was hated by
so many people oh my God reviews every
time he did a record the reviews would
just be like
the worst thing you could ever imagine
but but who cared [__] cared man
you're doing what you like to do and he
was a master at promoting himself he
would do interviews for a Zine of 20
people saw it you know he was always
doing scenes and interviews he'd do
whatever the hell it took to get his
name out there and over the course of
time he built up a following
and uh
he uh yeah
so so basically I did the Thrills thing
he did that
my band ended up breaking up
[Music]
82-83 somewhere around there maybe and I
was back to uh
live in a shitty [__] life I got
married to a [__] alcoholic that was
the worst three [__] years of my life
I was working in a [__] laundromat
doing people's [__] laundry and being
[__] miserable
Meanwhile my brother was out there
[__] raising hell and doing this and
that and I was like [__] man I got to
get back into this [__] you know
so
around
88 we decided we were going to um
try to put a band back together again
because at that point
he had been
playing shows and stuff but some some of
the times he would just pick up bands
in different cities sometimes he would
just show up to a gig with a Boombox and
and
do a spoken word and just do his
performance [__] and all that and he
hadn't had a real serious solid band in
in some time you know
um
we consider Gigi to be like the Chuck
Berry of punk rock
because he could have a band in every in
any given City in any given time and he
would show up and
sometimes they'd be okay sometimes they
would suck sometimes they wouldn't know
his songs and it wouldn't even matter
because he'd Go on stage and just
improvise anyway and do whatever he had
to do he was doing a lot of drinking so
he was really out of control
uh
and uh we we had started hanging out
more again
and I had gotten divorced at that point
and was single so
we decided that we would start a band
called the AIDS Brigade
so this would have been 19
um
we
it was me and my brother
uh Chris brokoff and another kid from
New Hampshire that was living in Boston
at the time
and we were rehearsing and Gigi was
writing a few songs
um
but this is Boston
and Boston at that time was very
conservative
and we ended up only playing one show
and the one show that we did play
we had to dress in Drag
to get into the show because Gigi had
been banned from the venue that we were
booked at
so when we booked the show we told the
venue that oh this is just a benefit
from my brother he won't be involved you
know and uh
but of course we all dressed in Drag and
we went and played the show
and that was uh it was 1989. in the
meantime in 1988 we had recorded
the homestead records single that my
brother had signed with homestead
records in the
later 80s so he did a record called You
Give Love a Bad Name with the holy man
he did a record with a band called bulge
which was actually a band called psycho
from Boston and that was an album called
freaks [__] drunks and Junkies
so but by 1988 we had recorded the uh
single which was
Gypsy [__] hanging out with Jim
and expose yourself to kids
so that was the single
but like I said at that time
Boston was very conservative
and uh
even just finding good people to play
with you know anybody that could play
really well didn't want to play with us
they thought we were a joke you know and
uh and the people that sucked wanted to
play with us and we didn't want somebody
that sucked we'd already been through
that stage you know we've sucked enough
in our life we wanted to be good for a
change right well all everything
derailed
the show we did with the AIDS Brigade in
August
of 89.
by September of 89 Gigi had been
arrested
and
was about to start a three-year prison
sentence
for intent to make intent to commit
bodily harm less than murder
there was an incident
in Michigan
when Gigi was playing with a band called
disappointments
and a girl had invited them
to her apartment for a gang bang
well
you know Gigi's gang bang and you
somebody else's gang bang are going to
be completely different
so I don't really believe she knew what
she was getting herself into
but
she got
she got tied up and cuffed up and abused
and beaten and uh
carved up
all kinds of [__] like that and uh
she ended up in the hospital
of course in the very beginning she
didn't blame Gigi she took the easy way
out like a lot of people do oh a bunch
of black guys attacked me and
but then when uh
when she wanted Gigi to marry her after
that happened and he refused
and she decided it was time to go to the
cops and
so my brother got arrested
and
started serving time at Jackson State
Prison in Michigan
and at that point
I had remarried
and
decided it was time to get out of Boston
because there was nothing going on there
anymore and we moved to New York City
and the plan was while Gigi was in
prison because the whole time Gigi was
in prison
he was writing he was you know doing
interviews he was doing everything he
could do to keep his name relevant and
keep it out there so people knew he was
still around and that he hadn't you know
buckled to the [__] system and
whatever
um
So the plan was I was going to move to
New York
I was going to find a band
and when Gigi got out of prison we would
start touring
now
neither one of us
had ever really
properly toward
you know I mean
my bands that were all basically local
bands you know we would play in New York
once in a while we'd play here and there
but touring never
and the same thing with Gigi you know I
mean a tour for Gigi back in the days
would be getting on a Greyhound bus and
like I said picking up a band here and
playing a show there and maybe you know
uh
being on the road for two or three weeks
and playing two or three shows you know
that was kind of the extent of
any kind of real Touring that was going
on I mean
I'd say more so the disappointments he
toured with Zen than with anyone else
but
not really you know so
the plan was you know he'd get out of
prison
which he did in 1991
and uh
at that time
I had met a guitar player who had
introduced me to dino sex
who is our naked drummer
and has been in this band since 1991 and
he's still with me today
30 [__] years later he's had a stroke
he's had throat cancer he's beat him
both
and he's still playing
so
uh
so that was the beginning of the murder
jockeys
um
Gigi got out of prison
August
91.
we played a few local shows
and then we went on the road
for the first time
now
GG was booking shows I was booking shows
like I said we had never
properly toured in our life
so
you can imagine what kind of a fiasco
the first tour was I mean we would play
a show in Texas we'd drive three days to
get to California to play another show
we drive like two or three days to cut
across somewhere else to play another
show it was really
stupidity and Insanity all at the same
time you know and you know I mean back
then nobody wanted to book it was hard
hard enough to get a show for my brother
as it was
you know but but he was booking shows
and I was booking shows and the first
time we went out together it was it was
I mean it was exciting it was it was boy
it was pretty [__] scary too you know
there were a lot of scary times on tour
with my brother I'm not afraid to admit
that but uh but it was great what kind
of fears
well you know when you got bottles wisen
by your [__] head you know and you're
not that's why we started wearing
helmets in 1993 because he would get the
crowd so rowdy
you know
a GGO in the audience
was
your best friend
before the show
and your worst nightmare
after the show
because
it wouldn't matter
how many beers you had with somebody
before the show and how great everything
was when Gigi hit that [__] stage he
became a psycho he became another
[__] animal and you could be cheering
him on with a beer one minute and have a
[__] fist in your [__] head the
next minute so
dude you made a lot of enemies during
shows
and there were many times where
we would get in the van and get chased
out of town our tires would get slashed
our [__] Windows would get broken I
mean
which which you know after a week in the
same van with my brother after
defecating on stage over and over we
were pretty happy to get a new van let
me tell you that
and then normally and that happened like
usually two or three times on a tour you
know I think Hertz finally decided to
stop renting to us you know it was it
was really that bad
you know
but um
yeah the first tour was kind of an
experiment
and uh
once we realized we could all
do this and we were all really enjoying
it we fired our guitar player because we
[__] hated him
and
at that time we had put an ad in the
Village Voice
we were looking for a guitar player
so
a young fellow named William Weber
answered the ad
he was a hot shot guitar player from
Cincinnati
but also
interesting enough
Dede Ramon answered the ad
so I nearly shook my pants when when my
phone rang and it was Dede Ramon asking
if he could audition for the murder
Junkies
I got off the phone I called my brother
up and we just [__] laughed our asses
off we were like what the [__] is going
on here you know I mean we couldn't
believe it we were like is this a joke
but it wasn't I mean I had and I had
seen Didi Didi was like a fixture on the
Lower East Side you know back in those
days
uh like all those guys were you know
and uh
so we set up an audition
and Bill Weber and d and Dede Ramon came
in and
after the audition we
and my brother were like well
Weber's great we got to get him in the
band
and we got to get Dede because he's
deedy right I gotta say no to DD Ramone
you want to play with the murder junkies
you're in baby
so
we spent a little bit of time hanging
out with DeDe and he would rehearse with
us and he would come and hang out with
us and stuff
uh
at that time also
[Music]
a young NYU filmmaker
named Todd Phillips
entered the scene
now
I met Todd Phillips
at a place called Kim's video
on Saint Mark's in the East Village it
was like the alternative
um
video store had all the like
old school horror the European horror
the you know all the cool stuff you
couldn't find at Blockbuster and places
like that right
so Todd Phillips was actually working
the counter
at Kim's video and I would go in there
every day because I was a bootlegger at
the time so I would go in there and rent
like all these obscure movies right I
take them home put the little tape over
the tab and make copies of them and then
I was making you know I was selling them
to people in bum [__] nowhere they
couldn't see that [__] so got to be
friends befriend Todd and uh found out
he was an NYU student and he wanted to
do a film
about my brother and us
so we were like cool yeah great
wonderful
so he was filming us and doing stuff and
uh
this is around the same time deity was
jamming with us a little bit and uh
we had a show set up
where Todd was going to come down and
film it was at a place called the bank
on the Lower East Side and uh we're all
hanging out in my apartment and this is
Dave's show people are down at the club
we're waiting for you know the film crew
is all down there DD's down there
waiting for us it would have been our
first gig with Dede right
and the club owner calls me
and goes wow you know you know you're
not going to be able to do this and
you're not going to be able to do that
and blah blah blah so the coborn is
yelling at me in one ear right
Gigi's yelling at me and the other guy
[__] that guy I'm not doing any I'll do
whatever the [__] I want right and the
car motor is yelling Gigi's yelling and
I'm in the middle and all of a sudden
the show's canceled
so
I think at that point
and we were we were getting ready to go
on tour with Didi there were already
flyers for shows that had Didi Ramon's
name on it and stuff and uh
I don't know I think DD got
disillusioned by the whole thing and you
know uh he his thing was like well I
wanted to leave the Ramones because I
didn't want any pressure you know and
then [__] like that and we're like
do you
we didn't really think he understood
what he was getting himself into
I think as it got closer to tour time
and seeing that show get canceled at the
bank
made him realize that he wasn't going to
be able to hang with us you know and he
left the band
no explanation no nothing left his amp
left everything you know
so that was the end of Didi so Dede left
the band and we did another tour in 91
and this time I did the booking
so
things went a little bit smoother
uh but
it was full of chaos and violence and
just
the same craziness that we had gotten
used to you know and uh
we really love I mean we really loved it
everybody loved what we were doing I
mean we did anyway I'm sure some of the
fans didn't love it but uh
we would you know some shows got shut
down some shows went over really well
there was fights at some shows and stuff
like that and uh
so we came back in 92 we started another
tour
and this time
didn't start out so well
we
had a show in Dalton Georgia
and
a lot of underage kids came to the show
a lot of underage drinking
I think about 30 people got arrested
and Gigi got arrested with Dino
and I think it was it must have been
like one of the first shows of the tour
very beginning of the tour because we
had no money
and all we had was enough money
to bail my brother out obviously we had
to bail my brother out because without a
singer we're not going anywhere right so
we had to leave Dino in jail
and we had to travel from Dalton Georgia
we went to Atlanta
now my brother had people there because
he knew people everywhere you know so we
picked up a drummer for the night
I forget his name but uh we picked up a
drama for the night
played the show got paid
drove all the way back to Dalton Georgia
bail Dino out and then had to drive all
the way to I think like New Orleans or
some [__]
some Far distant place where we were
playing that night or whatever
so that was the beginning of the tour
then
a half a dozen shows into the tour
now you got to remember Gigi's on parole
right
but he doesn't care
I'm going on [__] tour I don't give a
[__] I'm not supposed to leave the state
[__] you he doesn't give a [__] right so
you know
you're on parole
you're parading around the [__]
country
[Music]
you know all this violent [__] going on
around you you're getting arrested here
and there finally
in Austin Texas
Gigi gets nabbed
the extra died in back to Michigan the
tour is over we're like six days or a
week or something like that into the
tour tour is over Gigi's going back to
prison he's going to finish out his
three-year sentence
and that was the end of that
back home we go
so
okay
it's a little put a little derailing in
our plans but uh
so the next plan was okay Gigi's gonna
get out of prison in April 93.
so we spend
that whole year writing music
so we could record a new record
when Gigi got out of prison we were
ready to record
a brand new album
we hadn't done anything with him at that
point you know
and uh
so we're writing and rehearsing and
writing and rehearsing going through the
year of [__]
all that [__] Gigi gets out of prison
he's like send me the [__] songs
I sent him a copy of the songs and
literally
three [__] days later he's like book
the studio time I got the record all
done
and I'm like what
just sent you the [__] tape light
three days ago
that's my brother
so okay so we book
time
in a studio in New York
Don Fury's studio now Don Fury at the
time
was
a very well-known very well respected
engineer producer he was doing a lot of
the major hardcore bands I I'm sorry I
can't tell you the names but he was he
was doing a lot of
big hardcore bands he was actually doing
major label bands you know and uh
somebody was willing to put money up to
front the record so we were able to go
there and record now poor Don he's
thinking to himself
I don't know if I want these [__]
people in my studio you know I mean
he gave us a chance I got to give him
credit you know and uh
my brother was well behaved
he was on a mission he had a plan and
when my brother had [__] to do you know
the drugs and the alcohol went out the
door when there was something really
important that he needed to do
he could he could let all that [__] go
and get it done because that's
his first love you know
so he came in pretty sober pretty
straight
we recorded the [__] record called
brutality and bloodshed for all
and that was in April
then we hit the road in May
for what would be known as the terror in
America
1993 tour
it was billed as the most violent the
most you know outrageous uh tour in
music history at the time you know and
it lived up to its name it was just you
know when my brother
got out of prison
well before he went to prison
there was a lot more self-mutilating on
stage
when he got out of prison there was a
lot more violence
directed to the [__] crowd he was
pissed my brother got out of prison he
was pissed he was he wasn't the same he
was more violent
towards everybody
I mean my brother was
anti-social personality disorder he was
narcissistic
he didn't give a [__] what he did to
whoever he did it to he had no
conscience
he'd [__] put a cigarette out in your
face and [__] laugh at you you know
no [__] morals at all I mean
literally he was out of control you know
but but he was more out of control
towards other people and not abusing
himself as much
you know
so
we uh we did a whole tour of the whole
country lasted about a month month and a
half something like that
came back home
the tour was over but we wanted to play
the last show in New York City
before we kind of took a break you know
so we booked a show at a place called
the gas station
now the gas station was
just this building
with some sculptures outside it was like
on the Lower East Side on First Street
or Second Street or Avenue between
around Avenue B it was in a really
shitty neighborhood in New York
and uh
that would turn out to be the final show
um that day we all got together
we went over to a friend's house we were
hanging out
GG was doing lots of coke he was totally
[__] wired like I mean my brother was
wired
anyway like just naturally wired
he had no patience for anything so
cocaine and alcohol had already
been introduced that day
we get to the show
everything just went to [__]
sound system sucked there were no might
the microphones ended up
getting busted the first couple we ended
up playing three [__] songs
show got shut down Laurie's side turned
out into a [__] riot area I mean
there were kids in the [__] Street my
brother was [__] wandering the street
[__] naked
[__] cop cars [__] all over the
place they didn't [__] give a [__]
they weren't gonna touch him you know I
mean if they had arrested him he
probably would have still been alive the
next day but
anyway
between the
cocaine and the alcohol and
just the whole
show getting shut down my brother
frustrated wandering around the streets
on the Lower East Side with a bunch of
junkies you know trying to figure out
what they were going to do with the rest
of their day
Gigi ended up
at this [__] kid's house
and they started doing heroin now my
brother was not used to doing heroin he
wasn't a junkie
contrary to a lot of people's beliefs
because he OD'd everybody thinks my
brother was a junkie
not true
so you know between the cocaine and the
drugs and the alcohol and the heroin
he passed away and
during the night woke up the negative
everybody woke up the next morning my
brother's dead
I get called
had to go identify the [__] body all
that [__] I was just like wow what the
[__] going on here
so that was probably one of the worst
days of my life you know
and uh yeah it was over
and uh
had to deal with all that [__] then I
had to deal with you know everything
else that came along after that and uh
you know I've been doing that for the
last 30 [__] years now you know
fortunately for myself
the brutality and bloodshed for all
record
didn't get released until the fall of
that year
so
we really had no
intentions or no thoughts of keeping the
band together I mean
our singer's dead you know or he's gone
I mean that's that's the end of the
[__] dream right
well
when the record came out
we started getting really good reviews
from it you know and people were like
you know you should keep the band going
you should do this you should do that
and uh
you know I was kind of leery about it
but I mean
the record was really great and
everybody loved it and uh
and I wanted to keep playing you know I
wanted to keep doing what we were doing
I mean
so foolish me at the time
decided to give it a go let's let's
go out and talk because we hadn't even
played those songs I think we played a
few of them on the tour that we because
we'd written them before the tour so we
played a couple of them but I don't
think any of us were we were familiar
with them because we'd been playing them
Gigi wasn't as familiar with the vocals
because so we didn't play that many of
them on the 93 tour so in 1994
we decided to go out
and do a brutality and blood set for all
tour we uh recruited Jeff Clayton from a
band called anti-scene who was good
friends with us who had done a record
with Gigi in the past and had done
projects with my brother and we were
already friends so he stepped in and
sang with us on that tour
and
it went over okay you know people
in the beginning after Gigi died it was
very difficult hard to replace very well
yeah I mean there's no replacing we were
trying to replace Gigi
the Gigi that he was we were trying to
replace Gigi with someone that had the
same ideas but wasn't going to be Gigi
we weren't looking for a clone that was
definitely out so that was a problem
because we were getting all kinds of
people oh I could come in I can sit on
stage I can do this like yeah but you
suck so [__] you you know I mean you
can't sing you're you [__] [__] you you
know so we dealt with a lot of that
foreign
we did find a thing we had Mike Hudson
from the Pagan sang with us for a short
period of time he sucked so we had to
fire him and then Mike denied came along
another [__] junkie
so I'm now I got a junkie in my [__]
band
uh he died a few years ago but uh
we did do a record with him and we did
do a tour or two with him uh it was
really difficult because
you know you stop at a [__] rest area
to take a piss and get something to
drink and 10 minutes later you got to go
[__] kick in the [__] stall in the
bathroom because your [__] singer
sitting there with a needle in his arm
sitting on the toilet seat passed out
so that's the kind of [__] we had to
deal with in the mid to later 90s and
then
eventually it just got to be too much
and
in the early part of 1999 we decided to
call it a day
so
uh super interesting story
well yeah thank you what uh what would
you say is the most important thing
you've learned from that whole journey
with your family with Gigi
uh you know I I I say you have to do
what makes you happy and if other people
don't like it
then you you can't worry about what
other people think and and I've gotten
over that long ago because believe me
the hundreds of great things that people
say about me there's always going to be
some [__] out there that says oh
you're living off your brother's name
you're doing this you're doing that [__]
you I don't even care I don't care I
don't even look I don't even look at the
good reviews or the bad reviews anymore
because I don't even give a [__] what
anybody says you know I know what I'm
doing and as long as I enjoy what I'm
doing I'm going to continue to do it
like it or not you know
all right Merle thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah fascinating
thank you I mean there is more you know
maybe another time